yeah it looks great and
the sound is good is the sound okay
there in in
berkeley
okay i can't hear them but maybe yeah
it's good
okay all right good excellent okay good
so um
uh so let's go ahead so um i think we're
right on time so the
last talk of this um uh morning session
will be given by uh tony metter
and he's going to tell us about device
independent protocols from computational
assumptions so please take it away tony
yeah thank you very much both for the
introduction and the invitation
so we're going to stay right on on the
same theme
from the first two talks so greg kind of
started from this
this proof of quantumness protocol of
prakrisky and others
and talked about how to make this more
efficient and closer to actual
practical implementation and i'm going
to kind of start from a similar point
but then head in the exact
opposite direction and largely disregard
efficiency
and instead we'll try to sort of get a
more precise handle on on what the group
actually does
rather than you know just showing that
it's quantum
so that's the general goal um so more
specifically
um i'm going to talk about how we can in
this kind of
setting that greg and ermela already
introduced we can get something called
self-testing
and this is from this paper with tomatik
and
we can also get um device independent
quantum key distribution which is from
this paper with rotten arnold friedman
um under accolade angelo and if you do
that
right so the plan is that i'll start
with uh diq kd
and sort of remind you of the setting
for
standard eiq kd now the main feature of
this
is that security here so security of the
key
that such a protocol generates is based
on a bell inequality violation
and then we'll modify this setting to
what i'll call the computation of
the iqkb setting and the key difference
to before is that now we've removed one
assumption
which means that we can't base security
on fell inequality violations
any longer and i should clarify because
we just had greg's talk here i'm
really talking about you know standard
non-local about inequality violations
and not computational ones
so then you know we need something to to
replace the spelling equality violation
and
this is kind of the main technical tool
underlying this
at a protocol for computational
self-testing and i'll explain
what i mean by this right so
let's get started with uh qkd
so in any qkd protocol device
independent or device
dependent we have these three parties
alice bob and eve
and alice and bob here they have some
public
channel connecting them um and eve
is the eavesdropper who sort of you know
listens in on
what that's saying and what else and bob
would like to do is they would like to
turn this public channel into a private
one so one where eve doesn't
doesn't anything about what is being
communicated
and the additional resources that alice
and bob have
to to do this are shared and tangled
quantum states so here we need to be a
bit more
sort of precise um because alice and bob
are just classical people right so when
we say that they have shared quantum
states
really what we mean is that they have
some some quantum device some
experimental
setup on on either side and
these two devices here share entangled
states and alice and bob can
classically interact with these devices
so you can just imagine
pushing a button and reading stuff off a
screen
and now what makes such a protocol
device
independent is if we don't want to trust
that
these devices behave as advertised so
you know if you press
press the button that says make a
computational basis measurement
you don't want to assume that this is
actually what this device
does and also because the device is
untrusted we allow for the possibility
that it might be entangled with eve
so a storyteller that's usually told
here is that eve is actually the
manufacturer
of these devices and sort of maliciously
manufactures them
gives them to alice and bob and even
though alice and bob
only have these maliciously prepared
devices
they still want to generate a secure key
with them
so this is like quite a a weak um set of
assumptions in that it gives alice and
bob very little
but you can still generate a shared
secret key here
and roughly the the outline for this is
that you
have alice and bob interact with this
device and then compare
some statistics of their interaction
via this public channel and if they
observe
a bell inequality violation in these
statistics
then they can deduce some sort of
statement about
what state and measurements these
devices must have used internally
and from this knowledge of what
is going on inside the devices it's
possible to deduce
um that alice and bob can generate an
information theoretically secure final
key
from the input output behavior that they
had
with their devices so i really want to
stress here that information theoretic
security is like the
the key point here so this means that
even if eve
is computationally unbounded the key is
still
secure and that's kind of the main the
main advantage of
quantum key distribution in general over
just classical
public key crypto right
so we've kind of made a couple
hidden assumptions here which is that um
these devices they are untrusted they
can be entangled with eve
but they may not actually talk to eve
and likewise they may also not talk to
each other
and all of these you know communication
blockage um properties here they they
look kind of syntactically
similar but they're used in very
different ways so
the fact that the device can't talk to
eve this is almost trivially
a necessary requirement because
otherwise the device could just forward
everything
like its entire interaction with alice
and bob to eve and then even knows
everything that alice and bob know
lately he can't generate a key from that
okay so this is sort of a the most basic
of requirements that always needs to be
satisfied
on the other hand this assumption that
the two devices
between each other can't communicate
this is really just used for the bell
inequality
violation because clearly if these two
devices could communicate
then the bell inequality violation would
just be pretty meaningless
right so for the rest of the talk i'll
not
draw these um these barriers here but
that you should always have in mind that
if there's no explicit communication
channel then
communication is blocked
so now what we would like to to do here
is get rid
of of this communication blockage
between
the two devices this non-communication
assumption here
so we would like to modify the setting
to look more like like this
where now we have you know two devices
connected by a quantum channel or
currently just
one big device with with two terminals
one for allies and one for bob
and this is still supposed to be
untrusted
so why why would you want to go from
this to this
um so okay personally personally i think
it's just kind of an interesting
foundations type question whether you
can still get information theoretically
secure keys without this
non-communication assumption without
non-locality
but more practically if you actually
want to run this sort of protocol
you need some way of establishing the
shared entanglement between these two
sides
right so presumably the way you're going
to do this is you're going to have some
quantum channel
connecting these two sides anyway and so
what we say here is well let's just
make this quantum channel part of the
the untrusted device
okay so now that we've connected these
two sides
clearly we we can't rely on a bell
inequality violation
anymore since that's just meaningless if
there's no
no no communication assumption so we
need a new
um assumption to get us off the ground
here
and unsurprisingly and if you've seen
the previous two talks
we're going to assume that this device
here is computationally bounded
and cannot break first quantum crypto
and
specifically the post quantum crypto is
this exact same lwe based
um adaptive hardcore bit noisy trapdoor
pro free function
thing that formula and greg mentioned
so with this new assumption we can now
at least hope to replace
this spell inequality violation by some
interactive protocol that leverages this
computational assumption
and hopefully from this protocol we
would still be able to make some
statement about the device's states and
measurements
and then as before deduce information
theoretic security
of a final key
what i want to stress here is that um we
do make
a computational assumption about the
devices
but this adversary eve here remains
computationally unbounded
and this computational assumption is
only required to hold for the duration
of the protocol in a very similar way
to how the non-communication assumption
in bell scenarios is only
required to hold during rounds of the
protocol
so in other words we still want an
information theoretically secure final
key because
otherwise we might as well just go to a
classical public key crypto
but we want to achieve this information
directly secure final key
in this modified setting okay
now there's one additional requirement
that we would like
from such a protocol and sort of if we
compare these
these two settings here in this standard
setting
an honest device on honest pair of
devices
can succeed just by doing local
operations and having these pre-shared
epr pairs right and now we give the
device more freedom to communicate
but we would still preserve like to
preserve the same sort of completeness
statement so we would like to to still
have the property
that an honest device only has to use
this connection to establish
pre-shared epr pass so in other words we
you know we want to preserve
completeness from this side but we want
to
expand the set of devices against which
this is sound
i should say when i say preserve
completeness going from here to here
here we require like actual local
quantum computation
here we don't so it's not quite as
practical but
at least from the point of view of
non-local resources we don't want to add
anything
on the completeness side okay
so that's like the the list of of what
we want
now if we go back to the previous slide
we can be a bit more precise
in in how these steps are are gonna go
so this first step here um is going to
be played by this computational
self-testing protocol which i've
mentioned
in the outline and which i'll explain in
a minute
and what we want in terms of a statement
about the device's states and
measurements
is that the device must have prepared an
epr state
and measure the individual qubits of
this epr state
either in the computational and the
harder mark basis
depending on on what alice and bob
requested so you can imagine they have
you know
one button for each and we want to
ensure that if they press one button
then
you know the measurement that they ask
for actually corresponds to what the
device is doing
and then from this statement about the
the epr states and the single keyword
measurements
we want to get some certified entropy
of the device's measurement outcomes
conditioned on the side information
and it's kind of known and been known
for a very long time now that it once
you have the certified entropy
that um it allows you to get an
information theoretically secure
final key and then you can also kind of
see
why this computational assumption is
only required
for the duration of the protocol because
once we have ensured with the protocol
that the device has
measured an actual bonafide epr pad like
actual single qubit bases then the
output of
of that is sort of independent of the
computational assumption
right so this entropy it really is
entropy it's not some pseudo-randomness
or something
it's actual entropy and if you go back
and break the computational assumption
later on
it's still entropy so this is why this
assumption is only a sort of
temporary thing right
so this is all i i want to say about
vipkd
and i'll spend the rest of the talk um
talking about how we get this
computational self-testing protocol
now if there are questions about the vit
kd part and that might be a good time
or otherwise i'll see afterwards
okay so um there are questions then
let's keep going
so let's first again sort of state
precisely what we want from from this
computational self-testing protocol
so we want to have some protocol in this
setting
which is some classical interactive
protocol run by alice
and bob and at the end of this protocol
alice and bob should be able to decide
whether the device has
won or lost in this protocol
this is just standard terminology for
these kinds of protocols
and then the the statement that we want
is that if a computationally bounded
device
wins with probability at least close to
one then the state prepared by this
device must have been an epr pair
and the device must have measured each
qubit in the bases requested by alice
and bob
now all of this only holds up to global
changes of basis
and this is because alice and bob only
ever get to see
the classical measurement outcomes from
the device
right so if the device now does a global
change of basis meaning it applies some
unitary semisometry to all of its state
and all of its measurements then this
won't have any effect on the classical
outputs that alice and bob see and
therefore we can't actually hope to get
any leverage
over these global changes of basis
now just as a side comment for those of
you who are familiar with
sort of normal self-testing in this
spell scenario
you might be worried this this global
freedom here is
is too much because we are used to just
local changes of basis from the
standard bell-based setting
the reason that global changes of basis
are still
fine is that we're certifying the state
and the measurements at the same time
so really kind of certifying how the
measurement
acts on the state and this
relation between state and measurement
is is actually like
basis independent and this relations is
really what's required for the ipkd
so the actual basis doesn't doesn't play
a role
okay so this is the the statement that
we're going for
um now let's see how how we can get
there
and to get there i um want to
briefly talk about one piece of prior
work in this direction
which you can kind of view as a single
qubit version of computational
self-testing and this is called remote
state preparation and they were shown in
the setting by jorge and vidic
two years ago i guess so for this we
fix some set of single keyword states
let's say
0 1 plus and minus i mean they can do
like 10 states but we only really need
four and in this protocol
the kind of structure is that we have
some initial
rounds and between the the classical
verifier and this quantum
device that makes some clever use of
those quantum crypto kind of in a
similar way as
as ramola explained and at this point
in the protocol here an honest device so
one that behaves
as intended would have prepared
one of these four single keyword states
so then the verifier sends over some
measurement bases either computational
other marks so just a classical bit in
practice
and an honest device would then measure
its
prepared qubit in the spaces and report
back the result
and another guarantee that the this
protocol
gives is that if this device passes
all of the checks that the verifier
applies here
then it must have indeed prepared one of
these four states
and then also it must have measured this
prepared state
in the basis requested by the verifier
here
now one additional property which we
will need and if we want to turn this
into a self-testing protocol the epr
states
is that the verifier here knows which
one of these four states
um the approver has prepared the device
has prepared
but the device itself actually doesn't
know
so this may be a bit counter-intuitive
but it's kind of a
result of using post-quantum crypto here
which enables
the device to if it behaves honestly
prepare one of these four states
without ever quite knowing which state
it actually
did prepare in the end okay so this is
kind of hidden in the
first quantum crypto which which state
has been prepared
so if we want to take this kind of
protocol and
um extend it to a protocol for
self-testing epr states
and what what do we need to do well
firstly
dpr state is quite obviously a two qubit
state
and we want single qubit measurements on
this so
to even like make a meaningful statement
about two qubits
alice and bob will have to enforce some
sort of tensor product structure
on this device's global space and they
will have to do so
using purely this post quantum crypto
and their classical communication
secondly we don't just want any product
state we want an entangled two qubit
states
entangled across the stanza product
structure that alice and bob enforced
here
um and then finally and this is kind of
a reflection of what i said
the drqd protocol we want that an honest
device only has to use local
operations and pre-share dprks to
succeed
okay so i won't say too much about this
first step simply because it's kind of
the the technical one and it's very hard
to give
intuition for so we'll take this one for
granted and then see how we can do the
entanglement and remove global
operations
so let's suppose for a start that alice
and bob just have
two isolated devices and then each of
them can just run
this remote state preparation protocol
and by virtue of this protocol
and then they know that each device here
has prepared
one of these four steps so now comes
like the magic step
from the the slide the first one here
which i i don't
really have time to explain in detail
which says that
if we do the same thing but with one big
device
then the only way for this device to
succeed in this protocol
is by essentially treating each copy of
the rsp protocol here independently
and preparing two qubits independently
okay so yeah this kind of has the flavor
of a direct
product or parallel repetition type
theorem in
gcs right so
if we believe this and and we'll kind of
have to
then what's left to do is we need to
entangle um these two qubits somehow
okay so to see how this is done let me
first rewrite these
um four by four states like this so this
is like the first state zero zero zero
one one zero
one one and then so on and
to entangle them kind of a natural thing
to do would be to ask the device to just
apply a c naught gate
um on its two prepared qubits okay so we
could just ask the device to do this and
there are two problems here firstly
the c naught gate is a non-local gate
between these two sides
so this would mean that an honest device
now would have to perform this non-local
operation and we said we wanted to
avoid this so let's ignore this problem
for the moment
and there are still two other problems
um the first one
is uh if we now apply a c not gate or
ask the device to apply a c not gate on
top of the rsp protocol
it's not so clear that the original
guarantees that we get from the rsp
protocol
are still valid right and secondly we
also
actually need to certify that it did
apply this the c naught gate are
produced in a tangled state
so to see how this can be done let's
just consider what would happen if we
were to apply a signal
gate and what would happen is that these
first three families of states
would remain essentially invariant under
the c not so you do re-label states
you know like one zero get mapped to one
one and so on but you remain within
the same family of product states here
whereas these last four states done here
they get mapped to
bell states entangled states
so why is this useful well it's useful
because it tells us that
if alice and bob in their checks
essentially
undo the relabeling of states that the c
naught
sort of produced on these first three
families
then the guarantees from the rsp
protocol
essentially still apply at least if it's
plausible that they could
so these first three cases here still
allow us to certify
single keyword measurements as we did
when we didn't have
the c not gate and in this last case
down here
alice and bob can check that the answers
that the approver provides or the device
provides
have been like correlations which i just
mean that
you know the parities check out and for
this alice and bob
would use that classic communication
so now the final step is to combine
these two
and for this we're going to make use of
this blindness property of the rsp
protocol that i mentioned
so what this said was that the device
doesn't actually know which state it has
prepared
and specifically in in this instance it
also means that the device doesn't know
which one of these four cases it is in
so therefore it also at least
intuitively can't adapt
its behavior based on which case it's in
and this allows us to combine these two
statements and kind of carry over this
single qubit measurement certification
to the spell case done here and if we do
that then we
we get that we can certify single
keyword measurements on a bell state
okay so this now you know gives us
almost what we want we can now
certify a single keyboard measurements
on on dell states
the remaining issue is is the fact that
here we ask the device to perform this
non-local gate
so how can we get rid of this the basic
idea is that you can
do in general a c not gate by gate
teleportation
so the way this works is you just have
an appreciated epr state
and you do local measurements on the cpr
state and the state on which you want to
apply the c naught gate
and you're going to get some classical
outcomes and the post measurement state
will be
the c naught applied to the original
state
so and the unfortunate thing is that
they're like this additional
correction operators on the post
measurement state in a similar way as in
state teleportation
and the way to get rid of them is that
als and bob are just sort of
being told by the device what these were
and then they can essentially uncompute
the effect that these correction
operators had
okay so in this sense in this way
we can remove this this c naught gate
and replace it by
gate teleportation entirely without
any even classical communication between
the two sides of an honest device
okay so now we really have achieved what
we what we were after right we have
we have a protocol which allows us to
certify
these spell states in this kind of a
scenario
and as i told you about in the first
half um
we also know how to get the iqkd from
this
right so that's kind of all i want to
say about
our work but now we had like three
back-to-back talks
on these very closely related subjects
and
like all of us have referenced previous
work so just to wrap up the session
um i thought it might be useful to give
like a a bit of an
overview of this like where this feel of
using post quantum crypto
on quantum crew bus is this act so
we'll do this in the form of a like a
family tree
and the caveat to this is that a it's
not necessarily
meant to be exhaustive and b is kind of
my personal take so
take it take it for what you will um
but this this field of this idea this
originated in these two papers um this
one is the more well-known one this is
mahadev's
beautiful verification protocol for
quantum computations
and this proof of quantumness here is
what greg mentioned as well
and in his talk this paper by prakersky
and others
on proving quantumness and and
certifying randomness
so like neither of these strictly sort
of
builds on the other because they're
somewhat
well at least in its strict
interpretation the verification protocol
is not a proof of quantumness and
obviously
vice versa so just didn't put any errors
here and we'll treat them
somewhat sort of as independent strands
so if we start from the this proof of
quantum is protocol
um as we've seen in greg's talk and you
can
do that without this adaptive hardcore
bit and make it a whole lot more
efficient and also get this
nice conceptual relation to hell
inequalities
and it's also been shown that and greg
also mentioned this
that you can do this proof of
quantumness in a single round
in the random oracle model and it's also
been shown actually twice independently
that you can make these proofs of
quantumness or engineer them in such a
way
that an honest device only has to form a
constant depth
circuit which is obviously preferable
the practical
implementation and finally this is sort
of ongoing work
um that i'm involved in but um it's
ongoing nonetheless that greg also
mentioned
that people actually working on
experimentally implementing this
so there's no paper but it's been
mentioned at this aps meeting this year
so
you can look at this bulletin if you're
curious
right so this is kind of the the branch
of making this proof of quantumness
idea more efficient and more practical
um the other direction is to get you
know more functionality
than proving quantumness and the first
step in this direction was actually
already taken in this original paper
where they showed how to get certifiable
randomness
and we saw an irs talk um that now it's
possible to make this much more
efficient than in the original paper
um then building on this um
we we saw this remote state preparation
protocol which i mentioned um as well
and this builds on it in the following
way so you can kind of view
this randomness protocol as certifying
that the device has prepared a plus
state
and then measured it in the zero one
basis
so it's a bit like a remote state
preparation protocol but it's
it's not quite explicit enough and it
also can only be the plus state
so um this one can do a larger class of
states and
is also much more efficient and much
more explicit sorry
and based on this um we saw these two
um functionalities in this talk
and then somewhat separately from that
there's also a whole host of
variations and extensions of formulas
verification protocol
so just to mention a few and it's been
shown that this is a proof of
quantum knowledge which is it's kind of
like a different way of stating that a
prover
has a state than a self-test a somewhat
weaker way
um but but it's still cryptographically
very interesting
and it's been shown that this can be
made zero knowledge um actually
by vedic and by the same people um it's
been analyzed what happens if you do a
parallel repetition to get the
the soundness error down to a negligible
and it's also been extended to sampling
problems whereas the original one was
just for pqp
decision problems and yeah i guess there
are probably many more which i just
haven't listed here so this is kind of
at least my my personal overview of
where this is at
and it already naturally suggests some
um avenues for future work so
you know these these last three ones
down here they they have no
more efficient site branch to the left
right so this
this is really something that if we want
to
get any of these to practical stage
eventually then we'll also need more
efficient versions of those
and of course you can also imagine
pushing this further in terms of
functionalities
all right so i'll end here i'll just
briefly for references and for the
recording put up
like the four references to all of these
papers if you want to google any of them
as you can also use the archive numbers
here and yeah i'll end here and i'm
having to take questions
okay thanks thanks very much tony
so uh indeed we have time uh we have
quite a bit of time for
for questions so thanks for for um
for keeping us on track so um are there
any folks
who have questions i don't see any
questions in the chat or the q a here
on zoom are there any questions in the
room uh
hi tony okay just to clarify
um when alice and bob make measurements
you are assumed that the measurements
happen on their
device and that there's no communication
in that part right
so it's not like all the quantumness
could be stuffed on bob's side
and alice is just a communicator
wait so you mean you know the slides are
stuck i mean
the in the part where um you mean in
this kind of setting
yeah exactly when the remote state
preparation is done and the c9
question alice you're making the
assumption are you making the assumption
that
is only asking that and the
the description of what the device is
doing is restricted to one side
no so that i mean alice is asking it on
this side
but for an honest device would do it
locally on this side right but we do
allow that a dishonest device might just
you know sort of forward everything from
alice's side to bob's side
and do the entire quantumness part on
bob's side engine just forward back the
results
so it really is is fully general in the
sense that even the measurements can be
arbitrary and global
oh okay let's see thanks
yeah i have a question um so in
in the self-testing i guess you're
giving some like computational
rigidity argument at least saying that
the approver is really like
preparing the cpr pair and then
measuring do you know if these
techniques will
extend to some more complicated version
of this like the rigidity argument for
magic squares like actually
saying that really is doing these
particular xc measurements on
on more sets of epr pairs yeah so
yeah i guess this is a bit similar to
the question that somebody else break on
on
extending back to magic square so yeah i
someone
also tried a bit and i think in
principle it's probably possible but it
just gets very very
painful very quickly because these proof
techniques don't
scale super well um see i think
sort of one goal of this would be to
have
what what um mentioned in the last
questions
um to have like a generic compiler that
just takes
any sort of magic square like any
non-local game for which we have a
rigidity proof
in the bell setting and converts it into
a rigidity proof
in this computational setting um but
yeah currently we
we don't have that we don't know how to
do that
and it's not even known at this point
how to like
just prepare states in parallel so
like the self-testing protocol you know
it prepares two
states um but it's it's not even obvious
whether and how that can be scaled to
end states
i think it can but probably the proof
techniques that we have are not the ones
that
one should really use in scaling this to
end states
and and copies
so there's a there's a question in the q
a maybe i'll just read it it's from
daniel godzman so he asks
if i understand correctly the devices
can communicate with each other but not
with eve
is there a natural physical setting
where this is a reasonable assumption
when the devices are untrusted
yeah so this is a good question because
indeed there's like this
sort of asymmetry between where you
trust the devices not to communicate and
where you don't trust them not to
communicate
so i think the the the justification for
that is that
in the completeness like on the
completeness side of things if you
actually implement this
then there are two ways of doing it you
can have a one-way channel from eve to
the devices
or you can have a channel between the
two devices
and we'll consider the the latter
setting and then you actually have some
asymmetry between
you know the the device to eve can in
principle be
perfectly shielded because there needs
to be no connection
but between the two devices that does
have to be a connection
now i'll admit that this is like still a
somewhat artificial
setting and this is actually why i cared
about um another slideshow stuck again
well i mentioned this this requirement
that we won that
an honest device only has to do local
operations and appreciate epr pairs
right and the reason that we care about
this requirement is that if you ever get
to a practical
um implementation of this then i think
the
if the the use case would be that you
have
a dick id implementation where like
pretty
sure that you did a good job isolating
the devices so that they can't talk to
anything
but you still have this quantum channel
lying around between the two devices
and you like hope that they like you
ensure that they can't use it
in between rounds but maybe you have
like this little bit of
rest uncertainties i guess if even
device independent kkd
is is not good enough for you then you
could try to remove
this remaining sort of doubt as to the
security of the key because you have
this quantum channel lying around
with this um computational thing
um so yes it's really i think from a
practical point of view it you should
view it as a sort of layer on top
and if you have any lingering doubts as
to how well
the experimental colleagues implemented
this
okay thanks are there other questions
question
so um in your genealogy slide
i'm kind of curious about the you said
that there's
it's not obvious that the verification
of quantum computations protocol
is a proof or a test for quantumness
so um is there a
sense in which you it's not or
okay so this is yeah can maybe let me
expand on this a bit
and also like say how it relates to the
other stuff so
this is like a bit of a subtle point but
the way that formula shows the
verification
statement is you sort of
need to you convert the computational
problem
to like some hamiltonian construction
you need to show
that this hamiltonian has a low ground
state energy right this is this
history state construction at the time
and
so for this it suffices to show that
there exists a state
with respect to which the hamiltonian
has a low energy
so what he does is kind of
takes the protocol and from that in a
mathematical sense
constructs a state which has a low
energy with respect to this hamiltonian
which then is enough to verify that that
statement
but what she doesn't show is that the
prover must
actually have in a physically meaningful
sense prepared
this this low energy state it just sort
of exists in a mathematical sense
so then this proof of knowledge um thing
that i mentioned here fedex and jung
they show that like if this witness
state is hard to prepare
if the they show much more but the
intuition for
in this context is that if the witness
that is hard to prepare
then the witness state can be extracted
from the prover so in some sense it must
have been
present in the prover but if the witness
state is easy to prepare then the
extractor could have just
produced the state itself
so our proof of quantumness differs from
that and
or at least the one that they give here
is this is much closer to self-testing
or like
yeah these rigidity arguments where you
have actual observables and you show
that they anticommute
and this gives you a proof of
quantumness thing and these are like
the actual physical observables they
aren't just some mathematical
instruction so this is the sense in
which this is not a proof of quantumness
but a proof of knowledge
and this is a proof of quantumness it's
in the second
and the right-hand protocol had a
classical approver it wouldn't be able
to pass within
was that not so you said that again i
didn't get the audio or if in the
verification of quantum computations if
the
uh if the improvement were classical
then it wouldn't be able to pass the
protocol
so well so we um
[Music]
in the general case at least i don't
know how to prove that
it like we don't have any strategy how
to succeed
classically and it seems like it should
be impossible
and indeed if you restrict the
verification protocol to like
the basically the probably x hamiltonian
then on top of that you can run this
anti-commutation
proof to show that it's non-classical
but it somehow is is a bit hard to show
that
um like with the actual protocol that
emily uses for verification
that you really can't succeed
classically so
i mean to maybe someone knows how to
show this but to the best of my
knowledge it's kind of
not known which is frustrating
i agree i think
i mean what you're showing right is that
the distribution that you want to have
and the distribution that you're getting
are
like you know close enough and i suppose
yeah it's not clear if the distribution
is not like
art in some way you know i could imagine
like it's not actually hard to like
do it classically right and then still
if you can still come up with that
distribution but if you had some circuit
that like had a heart distribution then
certainly i would imagine that it's
classically mentioned
because it kind of just made that up so
i mean you could say that like if equals
bpp
then the product on the left is still a
group of continuous right but on the
right maybe it wouldn't necessarily be
right i guess i mean you can also
imagine that maybe if
the the proverb were classical then you
could use some rewinding argument that
you couldn't apply to a
quantum improvement
i'm not sure i mean i think this is a
an interesting interesting question i
mean more i think
really the the thing to go for here and
this is something that we are trying to
do at the moment is
you don't just want to show that it's
non-classical you actually want to show
like in some sense it really has
prepared this
the state that the circuit prepares
right because that's
like that's what the honor strategy does
and and it seems
rigid enough that that's what it should
do but yeah somewhere
it's quite hard to show
yes sure yeah
okay great are there any other questions
okay if not then uh let's thank tony
again and all the speakers from this
session
thanks
[Applause]
and um i think we're going to take a
half hour break and
the um the meeting will start up again
at 11 45 uh pacific time
kind of agree with you i think you could
probably